formal this simple technique find a  quiet place visualize your goal and  remember that you are amazing confidence  is an armor against the world says  medium service yeah we're the ghost  tones this is my sister along with a  gift  repeat your goal in your mind  here's the plan Angela will pretend she  sees a ghost will put on a damn good  show  and make some money you said you're  heard screaming yes angry told you I  just wanted a quiet house if you can  control the situation suddenly you can  influence others I have come to see if  you would consider leaving this house is  this your usual routine for all your  clients  it's all an act Angeles gift and you  hear that something's here  did you see her but really thought you  could help me  it's just house will you not have time I  thought of you could hear the voices  he'd be able to stop them  [Applause]  and remember that you are amazing  you  you